the Melbourne Mavericks are an
Australian overwatch contender series
team that are completely [ __ ] at an
ownership level and by that I mean the
owner allegedly placed bets on
pre-recorded matches signed players -
barely legal contracts didn't pay those
players and he's been missing in action
for the past two months
seriously nobody on the team has heard
from him since August this story is
insane and you are definitely gonna want
to hear more okay so that owner I
mentioned off the top is Mason white in
2018 Mason bought serenity a player
owned org for $1400 and then rebranded
them to the Melbourne Mavericks a team
he owns under his company Blanco Asset
Management Party Limited which sounds
like a front for some mob type [ __ ] and
things got weird
almost immediately now here's the deal
I've been talking to a lot of people
close to the team and they don't want
their names anywhere near this story so
they've asked that I've keep them
anonymous according to my sources Mason
allegedly plays bets on pre-recorded
matches during early seasons of The
Contender series now you might be
wondering sorry what up until June a lot
of The Contender Series games in places
like Korea and Australia were
pre-recorded and then streamed later on
due to time zone differences what this
means in terms of placing bets is that
if you already know the outcome of a
game before the general public does and
then you place a bet on that game what
you've done is just highly illegal and
according to my sources Mason often
asked for the game scores from his team
and other teams and then use the money
he won from those bets to fund the
Mavericks okay on to the players in the
contracts none of the players are being
paid instead the players are given game
fees $14 for losing a map and $24 for
winning a map to be very clear I reached
out to Mason about these allegations and
he got back to me pretty quickly which I
mean is cool but you know check in on
your team my man anyways the way Mason
explains it the players were paid a
salary based on the team standing in the
league but I read that contract and it
stipulates this salary as a bonus it's
not the salary in the way you and I
understand a salary it's literally a
bonus quote performance bonuses will be
awarded to the player based off their
placement in season three of overwatch
Caen
tenders Australia these bonuses will
take the form of a weekly salary for the
duration of contender season for and
weeks of practices leading up to the
season ten weeks in total the bonuses
are as follows
so basically first place you've got $150
second place you get $100 third fourth
you got 275 and then fifth through
eighth if in the standings you got fifty
bucks
okay now in the entire Mavericks history
the team hits second in one season
fourth in another season and then dead
last in this latest season and in
speaking to former Mavericks players
this salary was rarely paid on time week
to week in this contract it also states
that Mason apparently didn't have to pay
any payroll tax the players weren't
entitled to any sick leave and I quote
the player is not covered by National
Employment Standards this is basically a
list of Rights that everyone who works
in Australia gets and I don't think that
this dude gets to decide whether or not
those players have these rights and when
it comes to players leaving or
transferring to another team oh my god
doesn't get worse okay so if Mason or
the Mavericks were to axe a player
contract they'd have to give 45 days
written notice pretty standard stuff but
if a player wants to end a contract I
have no idea how much notice they had to
give because the contract switches
between seven and 14 days multiple times
and on top of that they have to give
Mason or the Mavericks $220 and if a
player wanted to transfer to a new team
that new team had to pay a transfer fee
of $6,000 okay but here's the thing if
you read the overwatch contender series
rules for even 30 seconds this 6k buyout
makes absolutely no sense just stick
with me all right now I'm basically
paraphrasing here but if a contender
series player wants to sign a contract
with an actual overwatch league team the
team owner needs to pay a one-time
transfer fee there is no minimum
transfer fee the maximum transfer fee
will be equal to 100 percent of the
average annual base salary plus any
applicable signing bonus in the players
overwatch League player agreement so for
example if the overwatch league contract
has a salary of $90,000 in a ten
thousand dollar signing bonus
then the team owner and the overwatch
league team could theoretically
negotiate a trance
between zero and a hundred thousand
dollars but the maverick players aren't
being paid anything so according to that
rule they shouldn't have any transfer
fee let alone a six thousand dollar
transfer fee now Mason says that this
specific rule only applies to a
contenders player signing with an
overwatch league team proper and that
the contender series plays by a
different set of rules well as of
recording I haven't found a different
set of rules so okay so let's recap this
quickly guy buys a team in a league
where no player is making more than a
few thousand outside of prize money
pretty much pays them nothing says that
the team doesn't have to abide by
employment law and that the players have
to pay him in order to leave as you can
imagine this contract did not go over
well and I spoke to former Mavericks
player oily about just how [ __ ]
poorly it went even send us those
contracts and we worked through them for
like a week with him but whenever we
actually asked something to be changed
he would just instead of actually
changing it he would just talk through
like why I was there it kind of got to
the point where he hadn't changed
anything but the season was about to
start so we kind of have just just go
with it okay so oily isn't digging the
Mavericks and he just wants to leave and
play for a heist another Australian org
Mason says sure just pay me that six
grand before you go now Mason and
highest went back and forth seemingly
trying to work out a deal and they got
nowhere so then oily actually plays for
heist for like two weeks because he
hasn't heard a word from Mason but hours
before the contender Series roster lock
and a game that heist was scheduled to
play Mason sent what basically amounts
to a cease and desist letter to oily /
discord so understandably oily backs off
and doesn't compete in the game but the
shitty part about all of this is that
this horrendous experience with an owner
who clearly doesn't know what he's doing
kill doilies love for overwatch yeah he
stopped playing and competing entirely
listen this story is insane and
unfortunately its impact in a player's
career now I know that we all thought we
were past this point of eSports is
history but it seems like this [ __ ] is
still happening thanks for watching if
you want more content like this hit the
sub button and ring that notification
four unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]